لنكن صريحي هذا البلد فرنسا لم يكن
تاريخيا بين الكبار في عالم كره القدم لكن
منذ ربع قرن وحتى الان لم يحقق اي بلد
انجازات كرويه مثل فرنسا اربعه نهائيات في
المونديال وكاسان وهناك رمز كبير لهذا
التحول واسمه زين الدين زيدان يقعد الى
عام
1998 عندما ربحت فرنسا كاس العالم بقياده
زين الدين او زيزو واقيمه الاحتفالات في
هذه الجاده هذه
تكررت الصوره
2018 وقبل اسابيع قليله انتظر الفرنسيون
انتصارا مماثلا على هذه الجاده لكن
الخساره امام الارجنتين تحولت بسرعه
اعصارا في كره القدم الفرنسيه والشباكا
كبيرا دخل فيه الجميع تقريبا رغم الخساره
في قطر تمت تمديد للمدرب جديد حتى 2026
بينما كانت الترشيحات والتمنيات تتجه الى
تصريحان يختصران الاسماء رئيس الاتحاد
الفرنسي لكره القدم لوالديك غاد يخرج
بتصريح مسلسل عندما سئل عن امكانيه ذهب
زيدان الى البرازيل للتدريب المنتخب هناك
قال لا يحرمني العمر يمكنه الذهاب الى حيث
يريد واقوى ردا اتى من النجم الجديد الذي
قال زيدان هو فرنسا يجب ان لا نقلل من
احترامه الاسطوره بعد كل السنوات
والانجازات
المتحضر من الجزائر وسيذكر الجميع هذا
التصريح للمدير السابق لمانشستر يونايتد
سر
اعطيني زيدان وعشوا قطعا من الخشب وسافوز
بدوري الابطال باريس